is there any relationship between
kurzweil's technological singularity and
the omega point and uaps
okay um
wow that's a hard question okay so
sherdon
is
his omega point
is something that's also called the
newest fear
and the relationship is that
both
okay both kurzweil
and chardon
are looking at
another kind of um atmosphere basically
um that links actually all of us
together
but it's a network and it's a network
that is
not
newest necessary it's it's a biosphere
it's kind of like a biosphere but it's
linked by it appears to me it's linked
somewhat telepathically or
uh it's like a neural network but
there's there's it's not it doesn't have
a platform like you know like digital
platform
it's a different sort of platform that
has formed on its own
um
biologically so
but it's it's a fascinating thing
and if you look at kurzweil's work too
especially the intro to singularity uh
that looks fairly spiritual you know he
talks about it as if he also has this
vision that's like a palpable vision
that he has so if you're if so if any of
your listeners are interested in that go
back and reread that first part the
first the introduction and the first
chapter of the singularity and it looks
to me similar to
books about this that have happened in
the past i mean it's very spiritual
let's put it that way um his the way
he's writing looks
um
it's fraught with kind of a spiritualism
to it
and how does this relate to ufos if at
all
okay so does it relate to ufos i think
that
no not necessarily i mean if you could
say that the kind of if you could look
at this from an evolutionary standpoint
such as carl jung does um
and also in my opinion so does
uh chardon okay what you're looking at
is you're looking at kind of like a
a spiritual progression of humanity okay
so this is what they're they're saying
they're basically saying that we're
progressing into
um a new state of being human and it
includes this network it includes a
network in which we can communicate with
each other on a different level than the
way in which language is used it's a
different sort of language and does that
how does that correspond to ufos it so
happens to
be a simultaneous
with what we call kind of in the in the
20th century the flying saucer right so
we see these these kinds of things and
so you called this a new archetype right
the image of the fine saucer a new
archetype so you can say that these kind
of happen at the same time and are they
related they're related in this way
they're related in the sense that there
is a a lot of people experience a
spiritual transformation when they they
encounter or see ufos um
the
the singularity and the newest fear
are also conceived of as being spiritual
in nature as well okay so um part of the
people that i'm talking with
today
and are people who
believe that there is there are
different types of networks there's the
network that we call the
internet right the digital
infrastructure the internet of things
there's going to be a biological network
now that we're you know the internet of
things is actually somewhat of a
biological network as well because we
interact with it physiologically
um
but then there's another network that's
separate from that and humans have been
on that network as well but they don't
identify it as such so
part of what i'm doing now is i'm kind
of like working out how people are
looking at this thing they called they
call a separate network than the network
that we hook into physically and
materially